like the rules of modern society have
led to everybody wants to blame
you got your prospectus if you just be
yourself but now some nurse
and now I'm riding through this
something's in the air
[Music]
we are
I can
[Music]
what what advice book what could we
learn for those of us on a more
traditional path from the
non-traditional folks that you record um
you know it's funny it's really hard to
ask a giraffe to be a penguin or vice
versa and so one thing that's become
much more obvious to me as I've gotten
older it's like wow DNA is powerful like
I'm so comfortable with no and losing
and fear but I'm so empathetic to people
that aren't I and this will surprise a
lot of you that maybe follow me I'm
unbelievably comfortable with
aggressiveness and candor and binary
talk on stage but one on one I've really
struggled over the last 25 years as an
executive with radical candor and
shooting it straight because I'm so
optimistic and I'm always trying to fix
it and so that's taken me a lot of work
and through that work I'm like okay you
know there's the things that come
natural and things that aren't if you
grew up in a framework with parents or
customs that really desperately
overvalue outside affirmation the
opinions of your parents as parents or
siblings because you come from let's
call it what it is an immigrant
background where there's a huge
commonality there school you were so
deeply bought into school that the short
term affirmation of every 90 days with
grades and report cards made you
comfortable it's very hard to then go
into hey hey this is what you should
learn from entrepreneur land like don't
worry about it it's all gonna be fine
that's very hard you've fully built
yourself as an animal to come
wheetly value outside judgment that is
not based on the market but based on
another human being that's what I'd like
people to learn which is like hey like
what are we doing here you've won the
400 trillion to one lottery of being a
human being do you really want to live
with regret like do you not understand
that the Internet is the greatest
optionality in the history of mankind
then our grandparents and everybody
behind them had nowhere close to the
options you sit with today and really
like what are you valuing that's making
you conform into doing something that
doesn't make you happy your current
overhead so sell your home in rent that
sounds crazy you know when I started
talking about like hey and the pursuit
of happiness would you consider selling
your home and renting I mean I got
destroyed in the comments sections and
it allowed to play like like that I'm
some horrible person I'm like how is
living your life to pay the bills that
you've created for yourself that's all
humans all that humans do or create
their own jails and then live within it
that's all we do so so knowing that
that's very hard in a human way the
situation you have with your parents all
that stuff the professional one feels
like I have a prayer of communicating
that and letting people that here's my
point if you want to be a professional
skier or if you want to start a blog or
podcast around cooking my big thing is
if you jump and start swimming you know
this is riding a bike
kissing a boy or girl or you know
swimming this is it seems super scary
until you do it and then you just laugh
about why I felt so scary like if you go
do that thing and live more humble limp
with judgment you could always get a job
again like I don't know like I just my
great fear is regret because it is the
obvious thing I see in people that are
80 to 100 years old that seemed super
scary
nobody was thrilled that they played it
safe it just you don't see it and I
think people should spend more time with
80 200 year old center at their
grandparents I mean it I mean it I think
people need context on life a little bit
I think people have a horrible
relationship with time do you don't we
people in this room are scared shitless
of 30 like it's some thing it means
nothing but our society's decided to
tell you that you have to figure it out
to marry the children and what are you
talking about 98% of the 59 year olds I
know don't have it figured out the hell
are we supposed to have it all figured
out at 30 25 like people are making
terrible decisions getting married
because they think they're supposed to
by this age you know like buying homes
because they think they're supposed the
rules of modern society have led to
everybody wants to blame
technology you know and drug companies
for you know all our problems we need to
blame our norms our expectations are
ridiculous Northstars that have make no
sense we're living when I look at this
young of a crowd they're living to a
hundred and ten there's an enormous
amount of people in here that are gonna
live to 110 and are freaking out that
they don't have it figured out by 30
you're not even a [ __ ] quarter of the
way there yet
you can bro thank you so much to like
appreciate it
[Music]
Dave they share what
[Music]
well we we wanted to respond to your
request around to video okay and so oh
no the kids nary happiness look at me
right Hey
when Gary called my name out the thread
I want to throw away yeah and like we
also have a good complaint right
everyone is working on yeah
so here's one thing this is the best
analogy I don't even want to have this
life if I can't do breaking news it's
very nice that you have a newscast at
the nice meeting this morning and we're
going to talk about the earthquake in
Africa and President Nixon's impeachment
but if a tornado takes out the entire
state of Mississippi we report on that I
need to be that I'm breaking news I
don't give a [ __ ] about your system
I want this [ __ ] video about me in
the Hat and we make that and then we're
just one day later on the next thing
that's how would you be treated and and
I won't be mad at you like oh I think
you guys have been here not that long
and already know that I changed my mind
on things long time I need to taste hey
guys sorry to interrupt your video I'm
just giving you this call for my number
to let you know that you have to join my
text community to one two nine three one
five seven three one hit me up with a
text does that make sense yeah because
like we go back and forth with this we
know the reason is always something we
want to get to but it's also we want to
make sure this [ __ ] is tested and
focused on your page that is the best
chance to win here's the good news
I don't ask often if I want the video of
this thing let's do it even though I
just told you if you don't test I'm
gonna die got it so the ask is more of a
one-off Bennett like hey I'm thinking
the system shifts this way gonna say
again I'm breaking news you're the
newscast you see what I don't like my
biggest thing is like like I see it
everywhere I'm like I don't
ask that often so if I'm asking like we
should do it there's there's I'm not in
the business of disrupting for the sake
of disrupting I mean I have a current
hypothesis that I need to taste
immediately well they're not I wouldn't
worry about this then okay because I
think I think we're just clarifying like
we were we were putting assistant place
where we're gonna get new clips out to
you every single day without you asking
just to make sure that you have new
clips coming through that are as tested
as we can get them on a two to three day
but what we can do that I want that and
then when I intuitively feel like we're
too [ __ ] all the clips then I'm gonna
be able to say what I have to say let me
ask a question when you're making notes
of like when we have that great eye
contact or like the [ __ ] happens next
[Music]
how what kind of delay Aleksei he not
gives you seven to four moments in time
he gives me he tells me which one's the
best one yeah and then that goes
straight into the cloud where everyone
air table get where it's there and what
happens next
all the platform owners then choose from
this from that day okay so if I log out
on today then they look at today and
they say like oh this is a clip that may
log from do you rock if they don't
choose it they could die yes
cool that's where we're broken here's
what I want them now on I want to hear
the clips we need to put me at the front
not the back it will work you'll see
good
that's where yeah that's the answer to
my question right now a month it where's
all my good [ __ ] sitting in the other
table not picked by Dustin Danielle or
Caleb or what the [ __ ] is why I want to
play not edited look let it out
done approved every clip gets put on
Twitter I have to think about how I want
to do that but the answer is yes like
whether it's Twitter or whether you guys
posted raw some what we got to think
about where I got figured that out
yeah not problem and even and a lot of
time we do put a lot on YouTube I still
think that this is art and we're missing
the biggest thing like the ideas the
ideas we have me for creative ideas I'm
really good
I'm comfortable now saying that we need
to use that as much as we can and when
we can't because I'm busy you're on
vacation
you do the best you can and then not
take hey we're at my clinic
negative moral right and then all it's a
negative it's not nothing negative yeah
this is a [ __ ] game of perpetuity
that being said we're [ __ ] Clips
right like like I know there's spa I
mean there's fire from some days where I
haven't seen a single clip fry I know
this I know that there was a [ __ ]
entire
four-day but where's everyone knows it I
mean avid not anything yeah so get it
figure out who's the best on our team
for headlining and idea in the clips and
then and the other thing is me adding
context and quick ways is really good to
like let's just figure it out it's
figure to forget there's nothing to say
I need to be bothered smartly and even
that's more like I'll shoot you wanna if
I'm busy or upset but this has for
sending you a lot of clips because I
think the rock poster just wanted to
show you how much we were pulling I
think if we sang you ten four or is
actually what we should have sang with
our best concepts I just want the fire D
bucks following me I'm paying him to
follow me [ __ ] around and not even
film to recognize off his talents being
with me for a long time so we can look
at each other of the five clips that
matter it's that valuable and I don't
have figure that oh that would that that
we can fix that I believe that's another
problem yeah fix that yeah this is just
communication this is good it's all good
my energy right now is more like
excitement than it is like I pumped but
just [ __ ] fix it
to your point the fact that I even have
them not gone like I have [ __ ] two
years prior is super fun but there's
been like things where I'd given the
look and I can't wait and now
intuitively like where's this I don't
need to be the poor so that's like hey
who's the where was the african-american
feeling what I can't get the look Jason
you made it no no it was very easy to
understand the system where were the
potential down yeah yeah we still don't
have the scale solution of like where we
gonna put it he's why we're having to
join the team Twitter's the scariest
place to do it because miss context
destroys you
that's what I think Raji like get team
Garry me on IG works cuz then you're
getting a raw version and they're well
produced version is on Gary so then you
like oh let me go see well you might be
diluting it on and some but that's okay
to like hot listen I'm not against it
some days I have time to look at it in
that context and other times you got and
by the way you guys should be smart
enough at this point to know that I'm
worried about misinterpretation it feels
like there's just there's tears
there's your special requests there's
things you've already flagged through
d-roc or the videographer of the day
those are things get elevated escalated
and done first and then there's ideation
it happens beyond those but those are
the ones that we cannot mess up that's a
damn sure that's breaking news but more
but equally as important is the [ __ ] is
he documenting like it we're always
upside down it's like everything else he
should be making it on the spot which is
why I don't want people one person to do
the whole thing Jason you got it and you
got it and you make it and you post it
and now do you that's why I always want
that system because I don't wanna hear
this Jason your filling you catch a six
fire you make it I'll see you in three
days when you're back from the cocoon
cuz you're going coast to coast and I
want to [ __ ] choke your throat if
it's the might will to blame right now
I'm in this cool
[Music]
yo good day going to the pencils of
promise gala I'm on the board
which is why I'm suited up which is rare
promise make me happy yeah there we go
it's a good day you rocks within me and
I'm telling Tyler I think Minnesota's
gonna be Penn State so I'm putting it on
the record Tyler doesn't think so
nor does most of the nation but I'll
stick with it see ya
[Music]